l'aménagement numérique du territoire
fait partie des engagements du président
de la république s'il faut bien
reconnaître au gouvernement une volonté
de mettre en oeuvre des solutions
efficaces sur le mobile notamment avec
le new deal sur le fixe les
interventions semble pour le moins
incohérente et l'efficacité très
incertaine revend plus d'un pari
hasardeux que deux choix mûrement
réfléchi
l'accélération promise se traduit en
effet par le biais d'une habile
communication a relégué le 100% ftth
pour tous à un horizon de dates qui
recule au fur et à mesure que l'on s'en
approche
j'en veut notamment pour preuve
l'apparition de cette date de 2022 dans
les nouvelles versions des conventions
des zones amis alors que jusqu'à présent
les opérateurs privés devaient inscrire
leurs intentions dans un calendrier
arrêté au 31 décembre 2020 certes des
engagements valent mieux quelles
intentions mais se secoue verront les
habitants qui nous intéresse au premier
chef
quant au résultat de l'accélération côté
hamel ils brillent par leur absence
vous avez présenté à cahors monsieur le
premier ministre 14 décembre 2017
ce nouveau dispositif temporaire comme
devant se terminer fin mai 2018
or retard après retard il aura fallu 18
mois au gouvernement pour accepter les
trois premiers dossiers plutôt que
d'accélération il convient de parler de
précipitation
or dans le même temps les réseaux
d'initiative publique sont fortement
accélérées au redéploiement au négocier
favorablement leur contrat de dsp
existant où on attribuer de nouveaux
toujours plus favorable
économe en argent public il convient de
clore les aventures hasardeuses de
l'état et rouvrir le guichet de
financement du plan français au débit
pour relancer la seule mécanique qui
fonctionne à présent et qui offre toutes
les garanties à l'état et aux
collectivités pour atteindre 100% ftth
les réseaux d'initiative publique
vous l'avez vous même reconnu récemment
par écrit en indiquant que la fermeture
du guichet était nécessaire pour que les
âmes elle est une petite chance de
succès la chance est passée le bilan et
on vend certes mais l'important
maintenant est de tourner la page et de
la tournée très vite monsieur premier
ministre et ouvrait immédiatement le
plan français au débit il est urgent de
remettre de la cohérence la pérennité et
de la visibilité dans l'aménagement
numérique pour le dynamisme
attractivité du territoire et de cesser
de jouer aux apprentis sorciers
il en va de la crédibilité dans les
blancs devant fermement en la matière
vont répondre la parole l'économie liste
de la cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales à mme jacqueline gros
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les sénateurs et mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
patrick chaize gouvernement
parlementaires élus locaux opérateurs
privés et citoyens partagent tous la
même ambition et le même objectif celui
d'assurer une couverture numérique
satisfaisante du territoire qui offre à
tous les français un accès au très haut
débit et à une qualité mobiles de
services mobiles de qualité pardon
depuis deux ans le gouvernement s'est
donné les moyens de mettre en oeuvre en
pleine collaboration avec l'ensemble des
acteurs dont les élus locaux les
objectifs ambitieux définis au niveau
national nous constatons que nos efforts
sont payants et l'accélération des
déploiements zones urbaines comme en
zone rurale est une réalité
chaque jour ouvré 13000 ligne en fibre
optique sont construites
cela représente 3,2 millions de lignes
ftth en 2018 et les chiffres du premier
trimestre 10 2010 neuf qui seront
annoncées demain vous le savez bien
marc une très forte accélération les
collectivités territoriales au
contribuer largement est fortement à
cette performance
en construisant près de 750 mille lignes
de fibre optique en 2018 ce qui
constitue un record pour les réseaux
d'initiative publique pour l'état ce
programme représente un effort financier
de 3,3 milliards d'euros et pour l'un
qui est cher à votre coeur c'est un
engagement de 91 millions d'euros sur la
réouverture du guichet monsieur le
sénateur que vous appelez de vos voeux
nous avons toujours dit qu'il fallait
avant toute décision vérifier dans
quelle mesure les acteurs privés dont
vous venez de parler était prêt à
financer leur à leurs frais le reste des
prises non financé on parle de 3 à 4
millions de prises sur un total de 34
millions vous le savez j'ai fixé une
date limite au 15 juin pour qu'ils
fassent par deux
toutes leurs instances leurs intentions
d'investissement date finale comme vous
l'avez rappelé vous même à partir de
cela nous ferons un diagnostic précis
territoire par territoire de ce que
représente le reste à faire et de ce que
cela représenterait comme effort
supplémentaire pour l'état
et comme engagements financiers ce
travail est fait en pleine collaboration
avec les territoires les associations
dont celle que vous présidez la lica je
vous remercie de l'action que vous menez
à nos côtés pour un meilleur aménagement
numérique de notre territoire